we are um tangibly driven animals um
metrics are important to us um targets
and goals are important to us and
and that's a good thing um abstract is
no good
it's not you know it wasn't work i mean
you can't run a marathon with no mile
markers
right it's actually unnerving i need to
know and be able to measure progress
but we have to understand the role that
metrics play metrics help us understand
um speed and distance right
and they're not absolutes it's to help
us gauge the problem is when they become
absolute so for example
can i get the pad back is that allowed i
can i can do with that
um so uh let's say somebody gives us a
goal
they say if you hit this target just i'm
a visual thinker sorry oh that's fine
so let's say somebody gives us a goal
thank you so much they say hit this
target
right if you hit this target you will
get a bonus
right and so one person on the team
is building uh making solid progress
building good systems
morale is really high very low turnover
you know and things are going pretty
well right it's a good team
and at the end of 12 months they didn't
reach the goal
we don't give that person a bonus right
by the way
it's arbitrary that it's 12 months
because that's when we pay taxes it
could be anything but
um versus somebody else on the team who
they can't hold on to employees morale
is terrible
um they're begging borrow and stealing
who knows what they're doing
they drop the price and on the right day
on the right time look at that
they hit the goal and we give that
person a bonus and that sends a piece of
that sends a message to the rest of the
organization which is we don't care how
you got there as long as you got there
i think that the goal is important it
helps us measure and helps us gauge
but if we miss the goal we have to look
at how we're doing
how we got there and i think that's one
of the things we don't consider
so how we get there will manage the
satisfaction these people are very
satisfied
and love coming to work these people not
so much they might be making more
money for now but in the long term these
people are your better employees
and so it's not one or the other it's
both and understand the role of money
inside an organization
money is fuel and fuel is very important
i think there's
i think money is is there's nothing
wrong with money it's just we have to
understand the purpose of money
right so the company is the car and
money is the fuel
so i don't care how amazing your just
causes and how wonderful your culture is
if you have no money you don't go
anywhere like you most
you might have bought the most beautiful
car you got no gas
you got nowhere to go the purpose of a
car is not to buy gas
the purpose of a company is not to make
money
the purpose of a car is to go somewhere
and fuel helps you get there
right the purpose of a company is to
accomplish something to advance a
greater cause to
contribute to society and money will
help you get there
very necessary very important but it's
not the reason we bought the car in the
first place
you